students that won the Jersey school say
that officials are dropping the ball on
a serious issue bullying the father of a
14 year old says bullying drove his
daughter to suicide today students
staged to walk out at Central Regional
High School to draw attention to a
pattern of bullying that they say the
district is ignoring
this was Brian Thompson is a Berkeley
Township and has his details
students at Central Regional High School
in the Bayville section of Berkeley
Township angry fearful over the suicide
death of one of their own after this
video was posted to social media last
week of several students attacking 14
year old Adriana cush walking with her
boyfriend in the hallway for no reason
yet disclosed two days later she took
her life at home her father outraged
police weren't called a kid is assaulted
with a weapon and it's not their policy
to call the police or to file a report
Michael Kush tells me his daughter was
taken to a nurse not the hospital even
though she blacked out and had bruising
over much of her body his outrage
reflected in the 200 or so students who
protested throughout the school day
skipping class demanding action if I
would like them to actually teach the
people who bully what they're actually
doing and how it affects them that
person is
what is that
that's that's if it's everything that
he's being bullied yeah he's speaking
from pain
that person's getting bullied that's for
sure one neighbor here even sharing this
video that shows her daughter drowning
in her backyard pool and Adriana jumping
in to save her life she was like his
daughter to me she was at my house
almost every day this demonstration
didn't end until the school day to
pizzeria owner Tony favola bringing pies
with a strong message of support inside
the police wouldn't let him cross to the
kids across the street the support
appreciated by Adriana's father who
thinks he knows the cause I do know why
it happened it happened because these
two haven't liked each other for a
couple years and she had been
threatening my daughter online but
school is not commenting at this point
only sending home a letter alerting
parents to Adriana's death Michael Kush
wants Justice it was a felony assault
they don't file a report that's
obstruction of justice they're
absolutely refusing to protect our
children I mean why would anybody want
to send their kids there we went by the
superintendent's office but have not
heard back the prosecutor is having no
comment but Kush says he's been told by
the prosecutor that criminal charges
will be filed against at least three of
the four girls who were involved in the
attack on his daughter
I tried so hard to just talk did you
just drive if you guys to listen to me
just for everybody here to try and
listen to us an outpouring of hurt and
anger finally ripped the cover off a
bullying crisis at Central Regional High
School as speakers many of them students
told raw personal stories of getting
tormented over and over again senior
Danielle Ledesma accused the school
board of ignoring their pain you are
here to practice
but
but darkest point of my life is you
completely abandoned me student Echo
McNichols described her Terror at
threats from bullies in class they told
me that I was ugly and fat that I have
to kill myself
um
they sent us pictures of guns and told
us that they knew where we lived and
they were going to send people to our
house to come reap us
and this whole solution was to tell me
to switch classes to turn my schedule
upside down in the middle of the year to
get away from these kids or to just suck
it up
they told her
they told it as switch classes
and to move her schedule around to get
away from them
yeah
we're scared to walk in the hallways of
central we're terrified we're gonna get
picked on and Boogie and jump because
that's all that's been happening these
last few weeks I had pictures taken of
me I had them post on Instagram Snapchat
every single social media platform I've
had people try to jump me because I'm
gay in this school and I've been
suicidal and I have self-harms in the
past because the things that have
happened to me in this school
I just didn't told to ignore it to be
the bigger person walk away the crowd
bristling with pent-up Fury vented their
frustration for hours at the grim-faced
board parents who've tried to get help
for Bully teams to no avail said they're
deeply alarmed because you monsters are
gonna be who's protecting her and I'm
feared you guys should always resign
okay every single one of you the thing
I've been hearing all night long and I
totally agree we have to do better but
we have no place in our school the board
promised change but earlier at a news
conference Acting Superintendent Doug
Corbett said he hadn't observed a
climate of violence in school here I see
a lot of good kids doing a lot of good
things
there's not a culture of violence do do
these things occur obviously we know
that throughout the country in every
school we work everything in our power
to prevent that
I haven't observed any violence
it's like a white person saying I'm not
getting stopped by the cops
like yeah you don't observe it but it
happens and I'm gonna do it in front of
you dumb dumb
it's like you're a super superintendent
they're not going to do it in front of
you they're going to do it in the
classrooms they're going to do it online
are you online and I have your account
no because you're a superintendent you
probably have other things to do than
chill with kids good on you because
that's just weird but of course you
don't see that of course you haven't
observed it
it's just
it's a funny it's always funny for me
like whenever people talk about I
haven't observed that when they're not
the one targeted they're not the one
they're not the one that this [__] is
about and they're like I haven't seen
that I don't know
you're a whole ass adult and people
don't always report to you they report
to people under you and the people under
those people
and the message doesn't go up to you
that's what you have to ask yourself
you're the superintendent you're hide up
there people don't go directly to you
you don't observe it like clearly there
is a problem my guy
if all these people are saying that and
let me tell you bullying is not bullying
is not like the the what what the movies
show where there is a club that does the
bullying and the club that are the Nerds
and this sometimes these clicks are a
little bit of everything I've seen some
jocks that are actually nerds I've seen
some people bully doing a little bit of
the bullying as well in retaliation or
for XYZ reasons so it's not as clear as
you can think it is but you being a
superintendent and being like I don't
have an observed it it's not for you to
observe bruh a chief of police doesn't
really necessarily know exactly what
goes on in the street until it gets
reported to him by the people under him
and the people that are in contact with
this cheats I haven't seen none of my
officers Shut Up And even if you ride
with your officers and you know you're
not gonna know because they're going to
act accordingly when this [__] happens
so whenever you're around they know
you're super and then so people are
going to act a certain way come on now B
just me saying that and having to say
that because you're like man it's just
stupid to me you're not targeted
it's not about you and you're not in a
position for you to witness that and
you're like I haven't seen that
it's weird to me but whatever what are
your thoughts about this whole topic
teenagers are ruthless men
I don't know what happens between the
first year that you get inside uh High
School
and the second year
but you go from Pokemon cards to let's
go all rally in the Pokemon cards here
poke that [__] in the [__]
so that too yeah yeah that that but that
too that too but you go you go from one
like from from elementary school to
another yeah to a whole other extreme
like I remember like I was in first year
of high school first and secondary one
whatever it's different systems anyways
I'm about 11 12. all right go to school
I'm done with elementary school I go to
that school and we go from elementary
school to I remember that the next
Summers I was still in the first year
we all met up in a park to fight and to
watch a fight like two groups was about
to fight I was like yeah we're about to
go see what's going and we become the
animals you know what I mean though you
know what I think it is though there's a
lot of things but what do you think it
is I really just think most of it's just
puberty yeah
yeah everything you hate your body
Embraces your face looking different
your body changed your voice change the
way people look at you no more people I
don't start looking at you different
yeah
that year when
you're when I'm at like Elementary
School today
was the year I stopped being a cute
I moved from cute to being a threat
people started to be scared of me some
people you know I mean I always started
to look like a man brought shoulders and
stuff like that it didn't that didn't
like get people to stop bullying me but
still you know I mean it's a whole lot
of things happening in your mind and
happening in your body and stuff like
that and then you have the other people
and other influences around you as well
you know you're not alone media changes
everything media is exactly so there's a
whole lot of thing and it's weird and
people are very very very very very very
cruel like we were cruel in elementary
school but the other step is is
something else so I can understand that
these things happen uh as a matter of
fact when I was in uh high school there
was something like that that happened in
other school another high school called
Jacques it was a dude
that was bullying a kid in that kid
committed and stuff like that and that
kid was living around my way right so it
was a big thing in the news and stuff
like that that happened where kids get
so much in the booing and then that they
commit
self-delete so it's something that I've
I've
experienced from afar because it was not
in my school I remember it was pretty
like a pretty dramatic thing
and then everybody was talking about it
and it was in the news
and then two weeks later
nothing and people went right back to
booking people went right back to
whatever the hell they were doing the
bullying and calling people a name oh
man my days I was you know I was I was
not black enough
yeah it was this dude bullying me always
always passing comments
she's lame
you little man looked like a monkey
anyways him in his Clique it's been
happening it's I think it's never really
gonna stop the only difference is that I
mean when I was a kid
once I got home that [__] stopped
there was no such thing as social media
or the social media was very very in
their beginning and stuff like that
there was no no Facebook no nothing if I
went home I went home that thing follows
them
you know when we live in a in an era
where there's likes and there's comments
so when that [__] got posted of her
being assaulted imagine you see
yourself being assaulted and all the
comments of haha the likes all the
comments you see that and
people feeding into that and there's
there's that culture of you're watching
that and then the same way that I don't
I don't think and you said that as well
you don't think that grown adults are
not every role model is meant to be
online and do uh do do commentary and
put yourself out there and see how
people react and stuff like that and
imagine a kid
a grown-ass adult that has the capacity
to be like you know what let me turn
that [__] off because it's too much
are not made most of the adults are not
made to be online and project their
ideas and being critiqued by everyone
imagine a kid that's growing up and so
that's what happened I think it's a bit
extreme but I can understand where it's
from it's close to me man like I've been
bullied you know what I mean
I've been bullied when I was a kid and I
was in elementary school I wanted to
commit suicide because of a lot of
things that happened you know I mean you
don't see your worth you don't say you
see it's a whole [__] spiral and [__]
like that so I I understand and I
sympathize it's a bit [__] up
you know
you you you know you know we had a
number of conversation about that [__]
and stuff so sure
so yeah there's a lot because it's a lot
bro
and in all these memories and [__] like
that yeah and those memories made the
man that I am today but
yo and this [__] is happening shh sh and
you're searching for yourself
like you don't even like yourself bruh
you don't like your own self you wake up
in the morning
you look at yourself in the mirror you
don't like what you see hmm
and then you go you go to school and you
get reminded
and then
teachers don't do [__] school don't do
[__]
and then you think you feel a little bit
more powerful when you're two you know I
mean you still get jumped nobody says
[__] and the comments and people sit
around and nobody said [__]
it's [__] up bro
it's one thing that you put yourself out
there and you have a channel called Abba
and preach
and you subject yourself to all these
comments that people say that was my
choice
I did that
you decided to put the video we
understand that [__]
she didn't ask for none of that [__]
someone filming you getting assaulted
you get there's a whole plot there you
feel like it's a whole company there's a
lot bro yeah
yeah we've already seen growing as
adults cry over criticism online what he
said about a young child or a teenager
having to hear that kind of quiz about
themselves that's already crazy now
imagine it's you getting beat up the
amount of shame that you feel
how terrified you are to go to school
how many people are probably in the
comments of that video saying do it to
her again she deserves it all of her
stuff so you find out even more people
want to harm you you know and like I
said most people most teenagers already
tackle so much self-worth issues for
kids of this generation even much more
so they're on Tick Tock their amount of
body dysmorphia and people who don't
like the way that they look and how they
feel about themselves like that's even
heightened due to social media right so
they're already in this like very very
vulnerable state in a weird way you know
like handy a kid a cell phone is not
just handing a kid a cell phone it's
handing them years of body issues is
hitting them potential access to
predators to handle them access to all
kinds of harmful message is handing them
a tool that honestly I don't even think
most kids are ready for okay that's why
parents got to put [__] locks on
everything and monitor their history and
everything else because you're like I
gave them but I gotta look because I
don't know what the [__] they're because
who knows what's looking back at them
you know that whole quarter about pure
pure long enough into the abyss and the
abyss stairs back at you that's your
cell phone
say that that's your cell phone say that
[__]
on to the whole topic of the school I
don't know how you can say there's a not
a culture of violence
and at the same time when violence gets
done on your grounds
filmed uploaded reported and you knew
nothing about it that is in cultural
violence you don't necessarily have to
see people get getting beat up
if when it's reported to you don't take
action that's a cultural violence
[Music]
you don't take her to the nurse you take
you don't take her to the hospital you
take her to the nurse you don't escalate
it when someone's assaulted with a
weapon
that's a culture of violence
that's you
think about how [__] up that is it's
not a crime where there was no evidence
this is not it's on camera uploaded by
the people who done [__] did it and
they all visible and you did nothing
they have the crime on camera yo but
schools have this way of thinking like
yo we don't want that kind of attention
we don't want that police presence we
don't want the headache of dealing with
angry parents so we gonna be hands up
but it's your job to protect these kids
I could be sympathetic if this happened
off school grounds with no cameras
involved he said I could understand that
on school ground using your dick in the
face in front of the cameras and you see
who did it that's your failure when a
student comes to you and shows you
messages of what people are sending them
in terms of I hope you get graped we're
going to be coming for you and they're
threatening and they're saying all these
foul things to the student even if it's
off ground if it's set online through
their own accounts you have to take down
consideration if your response to that
child hearing that kind of message is
change your classes whoo that's a
culture of violence and intimidation
okay forget school guys tell me what
workplace you guys could ever work at
he said owlette tell me what place you
guys could ever work at where someone
could come and dick you in the face on
camera record it upload it and nothing
happens and bro not even in the military
could that pass and HR the military
would actually come down on you hard if
you were Consulting people on camera
like that and HR is like change shifts
like like that kind of stuff is fringe
story but this happens at all kinds of
schools throughout the world because we
tell ourselves that violence amongst
children is no it's not the truth
that's some of their most formative
years that's when they're most at risk
that's when they're most vulnerable and
most knowledgeable that's when we have
to be the most attentive
and instead we do the opposite you know
I think that's what's unfortunate when I
watch this story it's
even though this life has been lost you
would think there would be a strong
response if anything all they're doing
it looks like they're trying to cover
their own ass
so
it's a very sad story the father you
know shout outs to him even though he
lost his daughter only 10 days ago he's
in front of the cameras trying to get
Justice for her and you know maybe being
a veteran a soldier is what helps him
keep his composure but I I don't know if
I could ever do that like 10 days after
I would be but who knows maybe he's
doing all his morning off camera any
chance he gets but like that's so
intensive an experience you know so
seeing him that composed to make that
case so strongly and eloquently was
really I thought that was pretty
powerful on his part uh but it's just
really sad
it's a really sad thing to hear I don't
personally have any experience with
being bullied I think one person would
try one time and then I just I beat that
person up and then nobody ever messed me
in high school I was too weird or crazy
looking that's Behavior I never liked
I never liked witnessing it I never
liked seeing it I never liked hearing
about it I just it to me it's just so
corny it's never something I'd want to
participate like [__] getting to get
on a group chat to gossip about somebody
calling all these other people like no
that's not me and um I would hope that
any young viewers were watching us and
who are in school uh I would hope that
you guys are not engaged in this
Behavior Uh because on Beyond it
becoming Unbecoming for yourself I just
think it's a you might be causing far
more harm long-term to other people than
you could ever imagine I'm not gonna be
the one that's going to be like hey
I was bullied I was bullied and [__]
that [__] I also believe oh yeah
I also bullied because at some point
there's no reason to bully there's no
good reason to bully but at some point
you want to take the Shine off you and I
gotta choose man
I gotta choose me and I gotta so I did I
did The Bullying I'm not gonna stand
there and tell you guys I haven't and
I'm all clean how much does that nope
no at some point I put on my bullying
shoes and I went on
because I had to
oh man yeah
yeah I did the bullying
that's what I'm saying that it's not
always that clear-cut yeah there's
another meme the bully's just a kid at
home who gets a beat every day by his
alcoholic dad
I mean it's a response to difficult
situations violence i'm like [__]
where'd you learn that from that's not
that's not so far off from the truth
that's a cry of help people booing and
doing all this all this extra stuff that
that's that's
either a lack of a lot of insecurities
coming up and stuff like that or
sometimes you just want to erase
yourself I gotta indulge in that you
don't want to do it but you got to do it
so it's very
it's very
yeah even the people that bully even if
it was a no it's just uh keep one go
ahead no I'm nothing I'm not gonna
finish
you're the people that bullied I'm like
sometimes I think about them I'm like
[__] I wish I could talk to them and
apologize I wish I could
it was one of our that was one I was one
I was at a show hosting for the show
and this guy Taps me on the shoulder and
I turn around and it was one of my high
school bullies
I'm like oh [__]
I don't know what was about to go down
imagine how [__] up it is
grown ass man how many years ago is it
okay
[__] Taps me on my shoulder
I turn around I see his face I recognize
him my fist clenched I was like I even I
even know
and he said hey I don't know if you
don't know you remember me I was like
[Music]
[Laughter]
and he's like yeah
um
I just want to say sorry for the past
and we're kids were stupid there's no
really a good reason like his apology
was the apology that you wish everybody
online too yeah he's like I [__] up I
was a stupid kid we were all stupid kids
and I shouldn't acted the way I acted
and I'm sorry about that and then I
kicked him in the nuts
do that tonight that didn't happen that
didn't happen but he told me I'm sorry
and he's like I'm a fan of what you do
and I really like what you do when you
need people like you and I will all that
was like all gone but still I wish I
could like meet some of my the people I
believe and I'd be like yo yeah I'm like
oh what are you a fan worth tickets of
thirty dollars he's like well this sign
said twenty thirty dollars stupid that's
called The Bullying tax [__] you and
[__] the past yeah give my money and
they kick him in the nuts yeah
so yeah so so yeah so so that's pretty
much it so shout outs to you but
um what's up man yeah man
well that is it for today's video listen
what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from everyone on
this topic so let us know